now when the first
covert 19 wave hit india millions of
migrant workers lost their jobs
strict lockdowns meant their source of
income in the cities was cut off
overnight
forcing many to move back to their
villages nearly a year
on many are still there but for rural
communities
it's been a blessing in disguise with
the returning migrant workers breathing
new life into their economies
the pandemic cost him his job
kanaram garasiya was working far from
home when the lockdown came
it took him four months to get back to
his village in rajasthan state
there he had family but no paid work
then he heard of training courses from
migrant laborers in the nearby city of
odaipur
now he's learning to operate a sewing
machine
before the lockdown i worked as a stone
mason with granite in the city of surat
i was there from 2012. the lockdown
announcement came so
suddenly everything was shut down and
prime minister modi said the government
would take care of us
but nothing happened we weren't even
allowed out on the street
the police would beat us with their
batons as soon as we left the house
for a thousand rupees or 11 euros the
step academy provides a one month
training course
including accommodation and meals
as well as textile work the school
offers a wide range of courses
from hairdressing to electrical
installation
as well as repairs to mobile phones and
cars
the school director believes the return
of migrant workers is good for the local
economy
because of the pandemic we've trained
around a thousand young people
many of them are found work locally or
open businesses
it's creating jobs because employers and
business owners are returning to the
villages
the step academy also partners with
local enterprises
who provide on-the-job training like
here on this construction site
the trainees earn a minimum wage and can
be fully qualified in 12 months
i worked in a kitchen in gujarat and
earned 5 000 rupees or
55 euros a month i had to work non-stop
even nights i came home just before the
lockdown and planned to stay here
the work is better and so are the wages
i'm home in the mornings and evenings
so i can help out with the housework
tejo ram is happy to be back on the land
despite the hardships
he and his wife live in a remote village
which they can only reach on foot
cities are okay but they're loud and
dirty
i'd much rather live in the village it's
better here
month of training is coming to an end
he's now contacting local tailors who
might offer him a job
he's determined to stay close to his
family and not return to surat or any
other large city to seek work
if i went far away again i couldn't look
after my children so i'd rather look for
work close to my village
and after a visit to a local shop his
hopes are high
the owner wanted proof of his sewing
skills and thanks to his training
kannaram was able to show him
once his course is over he's been
promised there'll be a job waiting for
him
well for more now i'm joined by dw
correspondent nemisha jaiswal
in delhi namisha not all migrant workers
displaced by the pandemic have
access to vocational training tell us
more about the scale
of this displacement and how the
pandemic has affected
migrant workers in general in india
well terry the impact on migrant workers
across the country
has been immense from delhi alone the
government estimates
that some 800 000 migrant workers left
during the second wave
and the ensuing curfews but many of
these people
told us that even back home they
struggled to find work
food was hard to come across and health
care of course
is not as good as it is in the cities
even for those who stayed back because
the curfew was extended week upon week
in many cities they struggled with
hunger and there was a problem with the
government rolling out provisions
efficiently as well
now curfews are gradually being lifted
but even going forward given the
prediction of a third wave
there is a high sense of insecurity
because many are still paying off the
debts they incurred
during the first wave so what if where
do things stand now
with the pandemic in india are
infections still rising are hospitals
able to cope
well infections are definitely coming
down terry they have
dipped below 50 000 that is still a very
high number
but given the comparison to the piece
that had crossed 400
000 things are improving the death toll
also is gradually declining however
some states are revising their death
toll numbers saying that they could have
been under counting
during the second wave and once again
with curfews listing governments are
emphatically saying
that please do not lack become lacks
about precautions
already the reports of markets seeing
surges in customers
so there are considerable regional
differences i understand what about
vaccinations how is the vaccine rollout
coming along
across india
well there is some positive news when it
comes to the vaccine rollout terry it
opened up for everybody above 18 in may
but the uptake was low and the supplies
were very low
finally supplies are improving the
government has recently revised its
policies for the state
once again and yesterday india actually
crossed
8 million doses in single day if this
trend continues
there is still hope that the country is
able to fight off the third wave or at
least diminish its impact
nimisha thank you very much for your
update as always that was dw's namisha
jaiswal in delhi
you